foreign
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Aaron goulette I'm the house chief of
staff I'm just here to get things kicked
off
um obviously you can see up here on our
presentation display uh the staff is
here to provide you with some some input
and some ideas
for your review and consideration so
we'll just uh have folks behind me from
both the house staff and the general
court staff to just go over
those items and be available for for
discussion and reference at any point in
time
um
with that I will hand it off to
Ann Fitzgerald who's our director of
house committee services and she'll
discuss with you the concept of
thank you Mr chair good afternoon
everyone here we are again
um I just want to my as you can see
we've laid out a portion again of
presentations by the staff as well as at
the conclusion we'll have
um information you requested our last
meeting
but um first item up for the piece I'm
doing right now is continuing education
and I just want to mention that we have
done as a member at us before we've done
continuing education in the past whether
it is for chairman
for freshmen at orientation or for the
entire membership where we have had a
full day just dedicated to study
commissions and
committees or a half day
um so we will be putting those proposals
again together for the speaker and we
have a panel made up of traditionally
it's a panel of staff and legislators as
well and we have a um
we go through every aspect of every
possible configuration of a study
commission so we plan to do that again
and we will have
um
that information for you moving forward
at one of our future meetings uh Dave
alicones will explain what the trifold
piece is as far as handouts go and then
we are going to look at how we could
design some videos to explain
um about members possibly requesting
study commissions and the background and
as you know we already have our video
set up from our first meeting when we
introduce the entire concept to you and
we keep asking staff to take a look at
that as well as members we have when
people ask say just please watch the
first hour and a half to understand the
background of study
committees and commissions so we have
our first before I into a video but
we'll organize a system for you later as
well but as you can imagine all of these
efforts take time as we're in the middle
of still of the legislative session we
want to put together a good product for
you to see in the future
so um
with that I can Aaron just turn it right
over to Dave right thank you
well wait did you have any questions
no I have one question it the uh
the the videos
with would it be appropriate to have uh
in continuing education uh for this
setting to be uh maybe the the two
different caucuses uh uh showing these
videos well that probably will be in the
future as we'll have all those proposals
designed for you so you can take we
should certainly consider that because
it's another Avenue to communicate with
the members um beyond our traditional
um programs that maybe the videos would
could be to somebody through caucuses
but we could talk about that as an
thank you again Dave alaconis OLS
director welcome Dave thank you much
representative we are
we have been talking uh the past uh
several weeks and one of the areas that
uh we'd like OS would like to pursue is
having a brochure that explains the
commission uh making process and the
questions that members should ask of
themselves and all others involved as
they come into our office
really by the time that we get that
email or they're in in our doorway it's
too late uh that filing period is uh
very intense time uh it's really not
it's not optimal to have that discussion
at that point so our goal is to have
something out there well in advance they
say a brochure it would be online also
of course there'd be information there
that is more than what OLS requests or
or needs in filing legislation so we
will be working with with Ann and house
committee services and anyone else in
this process uh you certainly as well to
uh to put something like that together
but it's that's a that's a component of
continuing education certainly we we
talked about the the questionnaire
at our point of entry in OLS and it's
the conclusion was that it has limited
use because once we take that
information in it is privileged
information so a member could say no I
didn't check with anyone no I didn't
talk to anyone and
it sits with us and you wouldn't no one
else would know that so that's kind of a
uh I don't think would meet what the
desires were when we talked about that
in the in the first in the first case so
uh moving back to the the continuing
education and having information out
there available uh before they come in
our door is is what we're going to be
focusing on
very good thank you
um
well I think we
spoke with Ann earlier we that's kind of
a hold out from when we were thinking
about doing the questionnaire in OLS and
uh but I think that would have limited
this is this is kind of a work in
progress from
some of the some of these slides from
last week uh that uh
again the question I will have much of
that same information that we suggest
that the member does in advance so we
want them to work together so that
any other questions from the committee
all right good afternoon I'm Jim ciancy
this is Paul Smith just kidding
uh
so we're here to talk just a little bit
about uh some of the
um the ways to increase visibility of
commission bills
um and one of the one of the few things
that we've discussed it so there was
this discussion earlier on about
creating a CN to add to the FN and in
discussion we sort of uh hovered around
the fact that we we really think they
would need to be done through
legislation additionally we get into
sort of a word suit problem
um you know think of hb2 HB 2 fnal CN so
we're we're getting into you know kind
of confusing uh terms here so what we
suggested
um and uh the by the way these points
are things that that we can handle
internally without actually having to
change law or or rules or anything uh
but the analysis and we we've
highlighted uh an example here from a
bill that was sponsored by John Hunt
regarding liquor every time we have a
bill that's an agency request we list
right on the analysis this on the front
page of each bill
that what the bill does in terms of the
analysis but also that it was an agency
request and OLS has agreed that they
will add in another line this bill
creates a commission or this bill
creates a statutory study so that is a
that's going to be a huge indicator
right there also in terms of we talked
about the check box before so I want to
explain a little bit about what that
means when we purchased our XM
legislator software suite back in 2015
it was sort of envisioned that we would
have this process to know right from the
very beginning whether or not we would
have
whether a bill would create a committee
or Commission
unfortunately due to some
misunderstandings and practices over the
years that really wasn't followed
through with however we have found uh
the problem and we've corrected that
problem so now once you go to file a
bill in OLS the attorney can check the
box right from the beginning
uh if a bill is amended along the pers
the process during the process at any
time either the house or the Senate
clerk also have access now to check that
box so if if a bill as as you know many
bills turn into studies
um so we have that ability to check that
during the committee process now or
during the uh the bills life so those
are things that that we we can do
without necessarily changing the process
additionally uh we have uh asked our I.T
folks
um you're all I'm I know you're all very
familiar with the advanced Bill data
search on our web page on that page are
a bunch of radio buttons at the bottom
uh where you can click certain things
that you want information and the IT
folks have told us that they can add a
statutory or a statutory committee or
commission radio button so that you can
search by that as as something that
would pull up a list for you of of bills
that were filed in any given year so
those are a couple of big things right
out the shoot that I think uh can can
help in terms of the visibility aspect
um again that analysis right on the
front page of every bill that's going to
be helpful in terms of of the speaker's
office uh in whether it's the speaker or
the deputy that's signing bills right
from the get-go and we could we're gonna
Circle back to that in a minute but
those the right right out the gate that
is a is a huge thing that that will you
know sort of be that that red alert
button
um that we we have knowledge of so uh
and Anne has uh this this bullet here
this consider HCS study profile
I'll just stand up it's probably easier
um so what this is is a plan we just
came up with this on Friday afternoon
that our office will
submit when a bill that is a study
commission comes to our to our knowledge
we're going to be proactive and create
you you all have a copy of it and create
this document like we're known for our
side by sides this would be on
oh I have them oh sorry
thank you
um
okay
sorry about that everyone
um so this will be
um a standard questionnaire that
uh our standard document I should say
that we prepare for the committee and we
will do research with the um sponsors of
the bill to find out whether the
commission is established through
introduction or an amendment
or if um make sure that it and see if we
can have a purpose statement provided by
the prime sponsor as to why the
commission is necessary does the bill
comply with RSA 1449
um has you can see you can read through
Singh has it we had a legislative study
committee or Commission in the last five
years why is it additional study
necessary is there a current study that
could be amended to include this charge
um if there are appointing authorities
for
non-legislative members and um if the
non-legislative member appointees have
been contacted or willing to participate
so these were items that we had
suggested to be in a questionnaire
within OLS and that's what David Dave
and I are talking about I'm seeing if
that's one place where we could initiate
these questions however when OLS gets
that information it must be confidential
but we might be able to find a way that
they could share that with us if it was
specifically requested that comes back
to house community services and then we
could forward on to the speaker's office
or give it out to our chairs and if we
can't do it there we would prepare this
document
for the committee so if you're the chair
of House Education every study
commission that comes before you whether
it's introduced or it is amended we
would the researcher will proactively
get this information for you and get it
to the chair
and because we want to Highlights since
we can't do as Paul mentioned the CN
designation this would just be one way
for these bills to stand out to the
committee to see that there's it's
Unique and that it's not just a regular
bill it has a commission a study
commission attached to it so this is all
just suggestions this is brainstorming
by the staff and we thought that this
might be a possibility to bring it
forward it to you obviously to consider
if this is an option
um it wouldn't require legislation it's
just um
staff practices but we just thought it
would be a helpful item for all of our
chairman and our committee members
uh let me ask the committee would uh
would you consider it worthwhile to have
an additional question on here something
like uh as this
posed committee or commission been
so that so that coming coming through
whether it's been endorsed by by the two
leadership our research is always
nonpartisan so that's not a role that we
would take out I think it's a different
discussion you'd have to have this is
so much for doing all this work
um
so I was just thinking about the whole
issue of bills being private when
they're formed and of course this I mean
when they're filed and of course the
subject matter is necessarily private
but these are just really like
procedural questions
you know so if you're concerned about
releasing the information during the
drafting process you know it's just like
has the appointing authority been
identified I mean it's not like you're
giving any great substantive issue about
the bill away
right I mean it's kind of just details
and I know this is an area where Dave
and I might have a little bit of a
disagreement I certainly respect their
you know the fact that they want to
maintain confidentiality with the
members particularly during Drafting and
there's a legitimate reason for doing
that
however um as you know representative
evil uh
the privilege belongs to the client and
there's
in my mind there's nothing that uh we
couldn't do that if if it's a
questionnaire or a way some sort of
waiver on behalf of the member if
particularly for study committees if
they wanted to have this information
made available to others the member
could waive that or they could be put on
notice
um as an option I'm not suggesting they
would be waiving their entire
confidentiality or even the substance of
the bill but those specific questions
you're talking about some of which would
be included in here some of which we
considered for the questionnaire
um I think we could certainly work on
that issue I don't think the
confidentiality issue is uh it's not
well I mean I that's what I was just
wondering where the confidentiality
requirement came from I mean the big
hurdle I would think for somebody who is
filing a bill is whether they're filing
the bill at all and whether they want
people to know that
um but none of this really uh gets I
that I can see gets to the substantive
nature of the bill it's more just the
details of the bill and if it is really
helpful in moving the process along I
Dave a question concerning
confidentiality that goes back to a
superior court case many many years ago
when outside bodies
individuals were seeking all the
information about how bills were filed
what was being presented by members and
so that is when the Court ruled that
this information that we receive is is
confidential yes remember Kenway can
wave it uh certainly if you want if any
member wants to bring in uh an outside
expert or agency or lobbyist they can
that certainly kind of opens up a good
part of things but that is that's the
origins and we try to keep a tight tight
lid on that but certainly uh
we can look at a prices that would
have a waiver for that that this
particular type of information so so
according to that stretching back to
that Superior Court ruling is the the
filing of the bill is it privilege
attorney client privileged
yes it's uh the information and all the
information that is uh that is there now
certainly in the house as soon as that
LSR is is entered and we give it a
number
that that current title at that point is
put on the website so that and only that
is made public so these the sponsor and
that working title is is made public all
the other information that comes in is
is is confidential
in the Senate of course the requesting
member can ask uh that the LSR title
be uh be
not disclosed and so if we look at the
LSR numbering uh you'll see many cases
that the numbers are missing and those
are most likely uh lsrs that kept
confidential in the Senate are the
sponsors and co-sponsors in the Senate
no they the the nothing is listed until
the bill actually becomes uh introduced
in the Senate
interesting
any other any questions yes it can so
I'm just trying to think through
why is it more helpful to have this
information Before the bill is actually
issued the text I'm just trying to think
think about the time you definitely want
this information I think provided to the
standing committees once the bill is
official and numbered and all that sort
of thing
um I think the reason why we initially
thought of this at that point was that
as a drafter is collecting the
information from the sponsor on the LSR
they could say have you done research to
see has this when was the study last or
what what information have you done
research because as we've stated earlier
we do know that there are some sponsors
who want an issue researched and they
believe that a commission is the vehicle
for that as opposed to turning to OLS
research or or our office if it's a full
committee so that's why at that point of
entry we were hoping and we did hear
from some members who have said oh I had
no idea that there was a study I mean
granted everything I can share will be
so anecdotal but it just uh highlights
that we thought maybe that point of
entry would help and would cut down on
some of them if they knew that um a
study Commission on marijuana was
completed just a year ago and and now
something's been recreated so that's why
but if that's not possible due to
confidentiality issues that possibly
that's we're going to explore some other
options but we thought this this would
be part way through system and also we
did find out
um that a good number of commissions are
created through through the amendment
process so that's another reason why we
thought it might make sense to do it
I was just trying to figure out
when you were thinking you'd give it to
the standing committees if the bill
wasn't actually introduced yet or what
the is is that it would be once the
Bill's introduced that's right yeah the
way it said draft I thought you meant
that makes it easier for me
I was thinking that would be that's it
that's clear it says draft because we
didn't want to make any assumptions we
were just proposing this idea we're
calling the paper a draft not the draft
LSA
[Music]
yeah
um Matt
um thank you for the work that you put
into this I'm curious if you've thought
at all about how this would apply to
Senate bills when they come over we're
going to talk about that in just a
go on
okay
great
um so uh
additionally uh we we did discuss
um there have been some suggestion and I
know it's come up in the past about
sending uh commissions to a second
committee and
um what I what I stressed at that
meeting
um and was that
we have a staggering amount of of second
committee bills and um for those of you
on the rules committee you also know
that there's a discussion every other
year as well about is there enough time
uh for us to act on those second
committee bills and um because
historically what's happened on a lot of
those second committee bills is they're
usually the last ones to come in uh so
we we are usually dealing with a with a
truncated amount of time and so rather
than than creating a requirement where
um all study commissions or committees
will go to a second committee for review
one of the thoughts was that we could
create a new standing committee that
deals exclusively with it or we could
amend the charge of one of the current
standing committees to be the repository
for all studies and I know uh we've
discussed in the past uh representative
evil it rules uh uh two terms ago where
legislative Administration could
possibly be the committee that houses
those but
um in in either in either way that is
that would be sort of a rules change
where we would create a new committee or
amend the charge of one of the
Committees and designate that all of
those bills go to that committee for the
hearing process now I understand
um in that process that it does take
away sort of the policy element in that
regard
um
but
we're we're up against the wall so to
speak right
um the the question is if if there's a
list like like and just uh suggested
there that
um you know each each standing committee
is still going to deal with with these
commissions and committees
um then then perhaps that that's a good
way to winnow it down uh the the reality
is that we
we we have a lot of these bills that
come at us and um
sometimes it's it's it's easier just to
look at it and say oh well it's just a
commission let's easy
hearing exec get it out of here
um but the reality is does it comply
with our new 1449 does it
um does it have is this actually a
legislative study committee or
commission
um and and trust me I've been having a
lot of conversations with some members
recently about is this a this we have
this commission that exists the the
opioid abatement fund uh is is a perfect
example of this
um a member has been repeatedly asking
me questions about it and I said this is
not a legislative study commission as
defined by RSA 1449 and and then it was
like finally a light bulb went off
um but but the reality is that
some of these things do get sort of
policy heavy and and the and the policy
committees might want to have that
oversight but if you want sort of a
winnowing Down
and and that's that's the political
question here do you want to winnow
these things down or do we want to
really just create a more formalized
mechanism
um I thought that what we did last year
with 1449 was a very very good positive
movement and I've defended that several
times in including in legislative
Administration where they just retained
SB 84
um so those are those are uh that's
where your suggestions and discussion
here are are going to be important
um and with
specifically answering this question if
you want to take this question up
any
what does what's the impact of what
we're starting to see now with language
coming from the Senate where it says
1449 notwithstanding
okay so let's move on to the next uh so
we can we can address that a little bit
more specifically so uh Jim and and uh I
worked on a little bit of rule language
um so I'm gonna pass a long
um
some a draft proposal here uh
now uh we all we all know that uh um
I will never uh besmirch the the body on
the other side of the wall that being
said you all are aware that of of their
concurrent resolution rule correct that
they won't take concurrent resolutions
unless they suspend their rules and and
agree to to introduce it well that's
sort of uh uh was the the thought
process here on um
potentially
addressing a similar a similarly
concerning issue on our side and that is
uh so the proposed language is no biller
amendment to any bill which either
establishes or amends any study
committee or commission shall be
introduced or considered by the house
which does not comply with the
provisions of house rules or statutes so
um I want to be very specific here last
week you all heard that the Senate uh
amended a study a new study Commission
on regarding uh marijuana being run as a
state-owned thing or a state operated
thing now the this amendment was not
crafted
stating notwithstanding
and in fact has a majority of outside
folks uh as the decision makers so this
clearly doesn't jive with RSA 1449 so
when it comes over if this rule were
here now we would take a vote whether or
not to even consider introducing it
um similar to what we've done in the
past if something has been indefinitely
postponed
um we we put the body we put the
question to the body as a whole as to
whether or not to introduce it because
usually we just introduce uh in recess
without any type of issue so this would
sort of address the 1449 issue
um
not saying that this is the beyond all
but it is a suggestion
um as to uh something that we might want
to consider to try to assist in that
regard
yeah and just to add a little bit um I
think part of it is resolving whatever
issues you know may arise in the Senate
whether it's the notwithstanding or this
amendment which we just learned about
last week that violates 1449 it doesn't
even have the notwithstanding language
but it also I think alleviates some of
the pressure that OLS deals with in the
sense that certainly they can advise and
they try to make the members aware of
1449 but if they are sort of being told
this is what I want I want a majority of
outside members and either use
notwithstanding or don't
um it's within the purview of the house
much like the Senate has their own rules
to determine what we're going to
consider and I think again obviously
this is within your discretion in
amending house rules but I'd say a good
place to start is making sure that our
processes what we consider are compliant
with the law and 1449 is the law and
I think in this limited aspect it makes
some sense to have a rule which says
we're only going to consider those bills
which comply with the law
what happens to those
uh rules that is it some pushback to the
Senate saying that that this doesn't uh
comply with our rules and therefore they
have to start over again or what so so
in that case what would happen
um similar to uh what happens when we
pass a concurrent resolution or
something along those lines
um we send messages with those bills to
the Senate uh what would happen in this
case they would send a message back
saying that they refused introduction uh
pursuant to Senate rule such and such so
that would be the same situation
um it's it's ministerial it the the work
is is it's all messaging and and that
sort of thing uh so if if they sent us a
bill
um they could once we returned it they
they have I mean the Senate could do
whatever the Senate wants but there are
actions in which they can undo things
that have been done so
that's uh that's within their their
powers
would die or stay on the not use on the
so it could die uh it could die in terms
of you know just sort of existing in The
Ether which is sometimes what happens we
we say that you know we have a
miscellaneous status sometimes in our in
our our advanced search
um that usually means the things that
don't fit neatly into a into a specific
uh category so in that in that situation
that would be a miscellaneous status
where the
um the bill just kind of died in The
Ether so it could come back in the
second year
um uh if they you know corrected it or
as I said that they they have options
um to undo perhaps what was done and
then perhaps send something different
over to us or
rescinded the amendment and pass it down
again and this is a discussion for you
all to have
um this is not I mean obviously uh you
know we have to go to house rules
committee uh with with any rules changes
but but you know it is a it is a
discussion point a starter if you will
yes I don't I don't have a question as
much as just a couple of comments so
um as far as the
as far as the issue of
um of
commissions and committees going to a
separate standing committee I think that
we really have to think hard about that
because that basically means that the
policy as as the clerk pointed out the
policy piece of that won't be going to a
policy committee it's going to be going
to a separate committee I I think that
would be
challenging I'm not sure how our
membership would feel about that when we
did our committee on committees one of
the things we really thought though
should that should go to ledge admin is
let at ledge admin on an ad hoc basis do
the review of the uh more more abund
commissions that aren't real weren't
really meeting as much you know so
alleged admin would be the one that
would decide whether to it would be sort
of like what our committee on committees
did that ledge admin would make the
recommendation as to maybe repealing a
commission
um
and
it would really work once we have our
system in place that house committee
Services is really tracking the
commissions that exist and how much they
need and all that kind of stuff they
would have the background data that they
could go ahead and do it on
um as far as the idea of a house rule to
to enforce 1449 I mean I don't think
that there's that much that's
particularly controversial in 1449
except the issue of requiring that the
legislative members of the commission
constitute the majority of a commission
and I mean I don't I don't know what the
Senate is doing but I would think one of
the things that they may be not with
notwithstanding is the membership the
majority membership of the com of the
commission being legislative members and
I understand where the idea for that
comes from you want to give the power to
the legislators but you know if people
are creating a stakeholder Commission
that part might be a hurdle so we might
want to think about that some more
foreign
to representative Evil's Point uh yeah
SB 84 definitely undoes entirely
everything good we did in 1449 last year
um it it it actually I mean it
it changes the the 15 member thing to
our actual chaptered studies which is is
silly in and of itself to me because we
have a hard enough time getting our our
you know three and two or four and one
um where the those folks actually show
up and participate so to suggest that
that should be 15 I thought was sort of
silly whereas they left the commissions
they sort of reverted back to basically
and let's be honest we all we all know
what the problem is here we know it's
the 45 member commissions that are Dr
driving the bus on legislative policy uh
that are outside of your all's control
and I think that that's a big concern
for many of us here in this room and
that is is something that SB 84
completely reverted to and I think that
that is sort of their policy that and I
think that's probably a fundamental
disagreement we have
um with them you know know one of the
good things that I thought did exist in
that in that bill uh that I think we
should look look forward to in terms of
of operational procedures is the outside
agencies hosting
um those those studies uh that are
conducted in those in those manner in
that manner um to the point about
legislative Administration I certainly
agree representative people I think that
legislative Administration has that
power now to do that
um the the chair has the ability to
create
um you know any type of subcommittee and
and frankly the subcommittee uh pursuant
to to the standing uh rule of
legislative Administration can actually
report to the full house floor without
even having to go to the full committee
so
um I do think uh we we do have that
ability and we should perhaps gently
nudge the committee to to maybe do that
on a buy-in biennial basis
um so I I definitely see your point and
and agree and again I I
for discussion purposes that's why we
had the the section uh about the second
committee versus a separate standing
committee I tend to agree with you I
think we don't want to necessarily take
that that policy uh
policy position away from from the
decision makers um you know somebody on
legislative Administration uh really
doesn't probably doesn't have much
understanding of the average Solid Waste
working group that environment
agriculture uh would so you know for
that for that reason alone I I tend to
agree with you but for for discussion
purposes we put it to you
yes I just
so um
what I think our uh committee on
committees had hoped was that the rule
that where you establish the
responsibilities for ledge admin we
actually would include you know add to
their responsibilities the requirement
that they review periodically the
existing commissions that was the idea
because I I agree with you they already
have that power but if you add to the
rule that they have the responsibility
to do it
um that would be good I just I I I hope
one of the things that comes out of this
is that there is somebody specifically
tasked with routinely reviewing uh the
commissions that exist because it's too
hard for 10 years to pass by and all of
a sudden we're going back to the way
well we had we have like every decade we
review everything but if those guys
could do it annually and with the
updated list I think that would help a
lot if if you'd like I'm I'm certainly
as you know I'm happy to work with you
on any amendments to rules um obviously
this fall we'll need to kind of come
back together anyway uh the rules
committee that is for other purposes and
presumably if if this commission if this
committee has additional rules
recommendations
um you know that would be good to
we have with us as both the speaker and
a speaker Emeritus uh
you have any comments about where the
recommendations are or what you might
like to see us uh focus on unless it's
better
the solid house
repeat what is already set my biggest
concern about admissions issue not only
putting stakeholders at the table we
were actually giving them above
responsible
thank you
thanks
we're just we're just digging in yes
representative thank you Mr chairman
thank you for all of you for being here
and telling us what you are saying
um I wouldn't want to put the full
responsibility with Legend men because
I'm thinking back when we were on when I
was on Judiciary we were quite capable
of deciding whether something should be
a commission or not I'm going back one
more time to the right to know
commission what a burden that became for
everybody
um
I think that committee could very well
have said let's dissolve the right to
know Commission because it was producing
nothing positive for years couldn't even
get a quorum so I wouldn't want the
total responsibility with one committee
I would like to believe that
um say if something went before Health
and Human Services for example
um they could say whether or not that
bill should Pass based on the
information contained in the bill and
what they would expect the commission to
accomplish
thanks yes
but in my understanding this critically
um ledge admin would be charged with
just once a biennium meeting with house
committee Services going over their list
and seeing which ones are not active and
creating legislation to yeah I remove
those right so it's not like
okay
it would depend however the the charge
is drafted in rules would be
I think one of the one of the biggest
issues we've had and and uh sure
uh representative shirtle can read me on
this it's finding people to serve on
these committees and commissions and I'm
sure you remember it was individual that
it's
when you've got many more than
five and five is pushing it
it becomes
nearly impossible to fill all those
seats
so when you're talking about commissions
that have maybe five reps and three
senators or two senators and 15 other
people on it if you were to reverse that
uh good luck finding enough people to
serve on it and having that commission
to ever even have enough to form a
be able to have a quorum you know to
meet
uh
I'm not sure which direction you want to
go
uh that's why you're here having all
these discussions
but
finding people who serve on these
committees and commissions consistently
is getting hotter and hotter
and especially sometimes when you have
they have to be a certain member a
certain amount from one Committee in a
certain amount from another committee
and then a certain amount from another
committee
now you're looking at calling all three
chairmen trying to find out who they
might recommend to be on it the time
that the staff is spending on this thing
is is ridiculous and it's tying up a
tremendous amount of time so I'm hoping
we can come to uh some solutions here
that will both help the staff and help
us get through these things but
um I'm trying to remember oh I know I
was thinking about the process in ledge
admin if we decided that there would be
some annual maintenance or biannual
maintenance
um I know it depends on how it's set up
in rules
I'm curious one of the ways to do that
is by introducing a bill that's just for
that purpose it's similar to the
you know the budget bills you know you
just you introduce something so you have
a vehicle that can then be used to get
rid of
you know sure like like an hb25 typed
yet right I I understand what you're
saying a placeholder type thing yep yep
good point good suggestion
I want to develop a little further
well just because otherwise otherwise
the work of the ledge admin committee or
subcommittee would would have some ideas
and say okay we want to dissolve these
committees or commissions but then they
don't have anything to it and then they
have to they have to attach it to a bill
that's
totally unrelated right so it could be
just at the beginning of every term just
like we do with hb1 and hb2 capital
budget you know you introduce an
additional bill that ledge admin could
then use for the purpose of dissolving
committees will be a standing standing
bill that would be reviewed every year
or every by every uh
yeah depending on what the rule was and
you know yeah I think that can be part
of further discussion I don't know that
we need to get to that today a good idea
because otherwise I mean what what like
what happened to us you make the
recommendation to repeal something and
then you have to introduce a bill the
next year and this way if you had sort
of a base you could just use it right
away
I think that's a good idea
just getting to the speaker's point and
having gone through this the the
assignment to commissions is just brutal
but I and you know not to get back to
the point again but you know we that
that's another thing to sort of balance
if you want if you I mean I love the
idea of capping the number of members at
15 but if we really want to make a
majority of each commission legislators
that does put more of a burden on the
appointment process and the lens ledge
the legislator participation so it's
just something to to think about but
another thing is you know in our um
standing committee chair
training which I really think they
should have their own sort of training
on how to review study committees so
they know what to look for they can be
asking their members okay well if you're
enthusiastic about it creating this are
you willing to participate in it I mean
sort of like our idea about asking
Senators well if you want to create this
thing are you willing to serve on it but
um
you know and take their names the
speaker has given me a few examples of
where requests have been made to create
uh
commission or or committee with the
just yes and just one other thought I
mean some of the study committees
that people are wanting to form are on
such unbelievably narrow topics that you
could also when you're talking to the
chairs or whatever they could talk to
their standing committees and say okay
well if this is something that you would
like to study and I know that Ian
Fitzgerald has mentioned this many times
there's no reason why a standing
committee can't study it as an ad hoc
yeah or as a subcommittee right to just
really do that work right within the in
the committee
because as I because some of them really
are I mean if you think a lot of these
study committees they meet maybe three
times I mean if it's a really narrow
subject a standing committee could do it
yes I guess going down that path
um would want to
make sure that all the power didn't rest
with the chair to establish that ad hoc
committee or
or the subcommittee
um
I think one when we think about how
study committees or commissions are
established right they go through the
legislative process the entire chamber
votes on it then it goes to the other
chamber
um it gives it puts a lot of power in
the chair and so I just want to figure
out how we can make sure that the
you know at least maybe the committee
has an opportunity to say we're we're
going to vote on this as a committee to
establish the subcommittee or
um
ad hoc is maybe a little bit different
it's kind of a little bit less formal
but
um and if the subcommittee is going to
be formed you know with some
expectations that they're going to
report back with some recommendations
yeah John uh I know for a fact that even
as we speak uh chairman hunt has charged
certain uh
parts of the government to bring back
reports so that we can work on bills
that we have retained so he kind of
sent that message out to them
so that we can work on the retained
bills without having a subcommittee or a
it's a matter of fact that we do this
so I I appreciate that and I do I do
think
um you've heard me use the term culture
before uh in in in respect with respect
to uh to these types of issues and and
unfortunately we we have sort of a
culture of of
um especially with one body where
a study commission hey it's it's a it's
a signed bill it's it's a it adds to my
uh my uh my past my past legislation
streak
um so you know there there is a culture
let's just study it and and and we'll
we'll have a report and if we file
legislation great if we don't whatever
um I I do think that we are looking to
change that conversation
um in in changing cultures can be kind
of hard so you know that's why the work
you're all doing is is so important here
because this is going to be a cultural
shift if we if we if we talk about
making some changes that are going to
affect statute or rules or or whatever
um that that is gonna that is gonna be a
a big a big hurdle it's going to be a
tough pill for some some folks as well
especially
yes
thank you very much you just made me
think of something Paul what are other
states doing
um do you know I'm sure you do
um can you tell us what processes they
use that might be more efficient than
ours uh well that's so
first off you're not going to find a
state as efficient as ours and and and
but it's true because the reason is that
every Bill gets a hearing every bill has
to go to the floor that's what separates
us from other states and and the fact is
that beyond that just the fact that we
have hearings and and a lot of bills get
subcommittees many states can't even
claim that so when we're talking about
our actual Deep dive studies I mean
a panel that reviews whether a
commission or committee should um study
but it's made up of legislators but it
doesn't go through the legislative
process it's just an outside commission
that you would have to go before with
your proposal on what you would like
studied
Wyoming or gen you you knew it right
Dave
but there but they're culture is very
different from ours where it seems like
the standing committees will basically
create like a study agenda for the
interim where they prioritize what their
study priorities are for the year they
go before um I think it's called the
legislative management Council if I'm
not mistaken
um for approval of those priorities and
then they go forth in the interim and
let me kind of review but uh my my
understanding of what's kind of on the
table right now is
is that we lean on leggy admin
to review what's
what's happening uh on some periodic
basis
and uh
and or
a special commission like this or a
committee like this that reviews
uh proposals for for
study commissions and the status of
ongoing commissions do I see those both
as competing no I got it wrong no I I
don't so the way the way legislative
Administration currently operates so
um their definition in rule does address
uh very specifically it says creation of
statutory and chapter study committees
and like entities which address the
legislature and its procedures so that's
that's their caveat now
um but it's about the legislature and
the legislative procedures so so that's
their purview at the moment we're
talking about
um I well it has been talked about about
creating a a a an additional charge
within legislative Administration that
on a biennial basis they will uh
sponsor or support a list of of bills or
review a biannual a biennial basis of of
commissions and that sort of thing that
can be repealed I will just mention too
that another great caveat of RSA 1449 is
that all new
commissions Sunset after five years so
that's that's a huge
um a huge win in terms of of being able
to call this in the future so if you
wanted to put something in rule I would
leave it nebulous enough that it doesn't
say specifically you know you have to
repeal this every single year or
whatever because in a few years
um if if if this group or the next group
comes together and repeals everything
that's old it can get be gotten rid of
um within five years all those other
ones are going to be gone anyway so
they're you know the charge is going to
exist but it won't necessarily be a an
active one so hopefully hopefully the
self-fulfilling prophecy is gonna it's
fill in the blank
standard piece of legislation at the
start of each session I'd say that we're
going to yeah I I think that's a good
idea I would suggest having it be in the
second year of the session
um similar to
um you know House Bill 2024 which is the
10-year plan because the in the second
year you're more likely to to have
results from the first year of research
or whatever because that first year you
know that that committee can can devote
to doing some of that leg work and then
in the second year you'd have that and
we do address in rule as well
um you know that that certain bills can
come in
um
is there any objection
visually
have that happen as part of the con the
consent calendar or is it at the all
these things well no you still have to
go through the process I mean the bill
would still have to have its hearing and
and all that sort of thing so it's not
um you know that it would be subject to
permissions are considered to be
dissolved it gives those
the chairs of those commissions or
members of those commissions or you know
industry that's impacted by those
commissions to come and make their case
absolutely whether or not they you know
do I know we want to keep going and
here's we're going to give you some
assurances that we're going to do this
in the right way we're going to be in
compliance with kind of the new rules of
protocols and standard operating
procedures of commissions moving forward
and that's why you still need the public
hearing process for for exactly for that
purpose and I think that's I would
rather and I think we're headed in this
direction would rather
as a committee spend time thinking about
the future
rather than this committee taking time
to look at all you know go through all
the different
committees and commissions that exist
and say oh we should cut these let's
leave that to
us so what that public sorry process
would that public hearing process happen
here it happened let's see admin it
would it would be legislative
Administration if that's if that's what
you want to do if that's the way you
want to craft it then yeah it would be
the policy committee that would have the
Okay so originally I was understanding
that we would work with house committee
Services because they kind of look over
this like they did for us today to tell
us the five that they feel that can be
repealed
would you continue to do that and then
you would bring that to ledge admin or
would it be our charge to go through
every commission and committee every
biennium well I think we would continue
to do that because as you're we are your
committee staff and you charge us with
doing work for you so I believe we'd
still be involved but as you know that's
probably a piece of working with I.T and
with Deborah to develop a good system
that will have that's electronic that
will help support all this but
absolutely we'd still be working with
you
thank you
um good question
um okay so we're talking process and the
demonstration taking care of this and
all I don't have a problem that
whatsoever it's a good idea
um what about the subject matter beyond
the process
uh
you have to one I would think whoever
handles these has to have an
understanding of what the subject is
that we would be establishing the
committee for that was not no no I uh
representative I I think the the
question is the bill that comes in the
second year
um you know in terms of because because
HCS is going to work with leg ad because
that that that's never going to change
they're we're not expecting you
representative Sheen to open up your you
know your notebook uh and with with
magnifying glasses that's that's not
nobody's suggesting that
um but I think with respect to a bill
that would come that would be crafted
um you know that notice of of when hey
these 10 commissions are on the chopping
block you know the chair either the
chair or HCS or the speaker's office
would reach out to those various chairs
of committees and say Hey FYI this bill
is on on the agenda next week or or
whatever
crafting that legislation well it would
be the same as in crafting any other so
where the the work is going to be done
by
the committee with y'all and and and the
committee itself can actually vote to
introduce legislation uh and bring
legislation forward so that's that's
something within the committee's purview
now they can vote you know in in the
fall uh to to introduce this legislation
uh it'll go through the drafting process
as any other bill would and get assigned
and that sort of Justice
yes
and if this is implemented within rules
bottom line this is going to eventually
help the speaker's office if we look at
this every biennium and cut off the dead
weight so to speak this is ultimately
going to help the speaker's office with
all the appointments I I do think so I I
do think that you know whether or not
you like the the language that was uh in
this proposal uh from Gemini
um you know whether you you want to go
forward with something like that I think
that definitely is going to be a
a catch
um that that is going to help I also
think that you know if if you want to
craft more more narrowly
um how whether it's in statute even if
you want to amend 1449 further in terms
of of of winnowing it down a bit
um and trying to uh to catch some of
these Rogue or runaway commissions then
then that's a potential as well but
that's why you're all getting the big
butts
um confirm again that house community
services will be working if LED Jazz
committee or any standing committee we
will work with you and that's why we're
trying to develop these systems to help
you look at whether it's subject matter
or the size of whatever it may be but
for instance another anecdotal situation
we had a researcher who worked with her
pointed out to the chair that this
commission was already in existence made
sure the community knew it but they
passed it anyway
so we will so that's why possibly some
other we're looking or or hoping you
will come up with other suggestions as
to how we can can guide we want to do
can we get for the chairs
um above the standing committees all the
policy communities but also see if
legislative Administration is another
tool just to find out why would you have
two commissions on a similar subject
which is one of the things that we're
trying to get at but we will make sure
that there are systems in place that all
the membership will know about and and
particularly the chairs through
continuing ed well do we need to modify
again I I that's up to you I I only
mentioned it if you wanted to sort of
make it more stringent again I do think
the section that's in SB 84 that's been
retained in like admin uh that deals
with the outside agencies hosting I do
think that that is a strong
um uh just based on our our experience
over the last two years of having these
outside groups uh state agencies hosting
I do think that that has has been
beneficial
Matt you had something I guess I just
wanted to refocus this on the culture
change piece and I think that some of
the work
you know that's been put together for
today's session just around trainings
and what kind of you know briefings need
to be made to chairs to the caucuses
Etc it's really important I mean it's
like this you don't just snap your
fingers and say okay we're gonna make
these changes and everyone's gonna
follow along and if things are going to
be different like this is about making
sure people really understand make sure
our colleagues really understand
why this is important why we're you know
proposing new rules changes why we're
proposing uh you know perhaps changes in
statute or why we're and or why we're
just saying hey there's this worksheet
that isn't going to require legislation
that you know OLS is going to be able to
you know work with members through
um to all of it all of it contributes
towards a culture change in the the
desired outcome which I think we all
share which is you know a smaller number
of these committees and commissions and
or at least you know a way to phase them
out if they're not being productive well
I I think truthfully even if you all
decide not to to do anything with rules
changes or the statute at the end of the
day I think that's fine the fact is that
we've changed the way we're going to
draft a legislation uh with the analysis
and the fact that we're going to make
those more searchable right on our
Advanced Bill search I think that is
going to be exponentially beneficial to
you all
um not just to you all but to all
members and to the outside world
so so does it does it make sense are we
in some agreement here that when Anne
develops that video training
that we take that to our
to our caucuses and share that training
and advocate
for these uh this cultural change
well Mr chair could we possibly maybe in
a future meeting we could bring forward
what we've done in the past so that
many people who are
some people who are new would find out
what we've done before as far as can
chewing it and show you
um it can be added to your binder but
show you the examples of what we've
covered and how we've done that all and
then proceed with the videos but just to
show you the work that's been done so
you can look at that and um
see if that's how you want to proceed
very powerful if the caucus leaders
bring forth a very similar message to
their membership
this is a new way of doing business it's
a cultural change we need to embrace
this going forward and we need to all
work together I think I think that would
be a very powerful message
but we wouldn't we're going to need to
come to grips with us and have a
hand-holding session before before we
before we before we leave uh that time
if I may Mr chairman I do want to just
say you know working within over the
years on on these things I mean our
Focus has always been from a nonpartisan
standpoint and and when we have
continuing education sessions they are
always non-political so if you're
nonpartisan all staff is nonpartisan
except for your the
um to
the dissemination process right but so
we would not be part of that I mean we
usually aren't so all of the canoeing Ed
has always been for all the membership
and as and obviously chairs
um but I know that I actually have given
Dan Mason some messages say could you
ask some ranking members during your
meetings to just remind them of meeting
the deadlines for the calendar for
instance for committee reports things of
that nature but for the most part as
Paul said we never step foot into a
conference
let me throw this out is there a better
dissemination process other other than
a caucus session the continuing the
continuing education that's why I had
asked if we could come back and I can
show you exactly what we did for those
full day programs or have to use the
speaker because we used to have a
continuing education program that went
throughout the year we had all different
subjects and that stopped obviously with
covid as everything else has and
obviously now that we're getting back
into the swing of things that may be
something we we haven't had the
opportunity to meet with the speaker yet
but that also it's it's a bipartisan
effort in education the panelists are
both represent both caucuses but we just
a good majority of your staff don't
think in term of caucus I think in terms
of the entire house
of it would it be a session in the in
the hall
that's where we've had them or 210 to 11
we're in the hall usually 2 10 to 11 is
a better venue and we have panels and it
goes all day we start at 9 00 A.M
tea coffee
um continental breakfast and then we go
in and we have subject matters and we
and that's why I want you to see these
and we've had them every two or two to
three years for well it goes all the way
back to the um late 80s so we've had
these info sessions
so in with the caucus role be to promote
the Uptown upcoming continuing ed or
maybe to I think so but we urge people
I think that would that would help but I
also think that we we put a box that's
how the Box the Box in your house
calendar it started from continuing ed
now the box where we highlight any
information we want you to have that
would go there and then also speakers
message has it and it's nest on the
floor and then of course the support the
support when you're in the caucuses
would be another Avenue to get the
information out but it's also trying to
get make sure people attend that that's
very helpful because you can work as
hard as we can but
people who should attend don't always
attend and it's but it's good info
session but then hopefully the videos
would
um they would be able to sit and listen
to the video yeah well I was just
wondering as far as timing when we could
have a continuing education
on this not sure I mean I don't know if
we can get it in before I get an ID on
that I was going to feel filing coming
and
I was going to ask the speaker about
that when we could have a an area we
could have a day
um to do that because
you're right with the bill filing and to
get people because we they are well
attended um when we had these in the
past remember we were up actually we
were 306 308 because I remember we had
about
um at least 120 and sometimes as many as
150 members show
for these continent programs that's what
was my concern yes they showed that's
why I was thinking caucus mean because
people typically attend the caucus
Museum they do show up looking for a way
to get higher attendance the last time
and we have people out in the hall with
all the doors open listening so as you
know Repsol can often be if you don't
have 400 people in there the Acoustics
can sometimes be difficult so that's why
we like to do it in committee room but
um we did we had a huge
um crowd who must have had at least
chairs and other members present
throughout the day as well as staff do
we open those those training sessions to
the public or to the press or anything
no
um well not typically because it's
continuing education for the members so
you want the members participating and
oh thank you Mr chairman just sitting
here thinking about a lot of the good
classes come up already I was wondering
as part of the betting process for
commission bills if they wouldn't go
before the Rules Committee just the same
methodology there's a late filing they
need to build that the rules committee
threat those questions in about the
performance to see that the members
already done their homework on this bill
it's just tougher to think about thank
you
any other comments
yes yeah I just have a couple so I just
wanted to point out on this question of
the ledge admin responsibility for
reviewing old commission so already in
our statute house incentive committee
services are jointly preparing an
updated index of all the commissions
with relevant information annually so
they're going to be doing that and
that's really building on the the charts
and everything that we had for our
original committee on committees so in
some ways just sort of tracking what we
did but it was really
um it wasn't substantive based at all it
was really just an objective review of
who was still doing their function the
other thing we did do is there are many
stat there are many commission
requirements or statutes that are flying
around out there that need cleaning up
so we did a little bit of that the other
thing that we did is we redo some
legislative membership so you can do
some of those sorts of things part of
the ledge admin role and I really really
think as we make more and more progress
we always have our charts updated we
have these new rules in place the over
time it'll help the speaker's office and
we ought to be diminishing in the number
of of commissions that are hanging
around out there
so I guess the only other thing I was
really hoping to see from OLS is this
sort of template that you guys do use
for creating study committee and
commissions they have to fill in the
blanks you know
you had talked about that as sort of a
computer I I think it would be really
helpful to see a form that's being used
that you have to fill in when you're
creating one of these things because we
have the q q and A's here but sometimes
it's good to just see the template the
template again that's it's built into
the uh software that we use but we can
certainly uh
print it out bring a print out of that
uh that shows uh a bill in process if
you will with the the grayed out areas
for
that get filled in
it would certainly be good for part of
the training yeah well I just think it
would be really helpful because then you
can see when you know when when
somebody's going to go in there to
create a committee or commission they're
going to be asked every single one of
these questions I know they're here too
but it's also just nice to see the form
it would be how and I think it would be
helpful
for the committee to see what that looks
like
agreed good idea because maybe we're
missing something we'll get that out
okay
the next item that we have is um
the commissions to review which we
handed out to you
um
and and
there were so as we discussed at the
last meeting when we were asked to look
this up we knew that representative's
two studies had
pretty much cult as much as possible
they had really gone through the list in
a very
um deliberative and
um substantial way and you can see again
that's in your binder uh in the reports
you see the questionnaire they had
submitted to all those groups so when we
talked with representative evil we
thought there would only be maybe 10 or
less and we found five
um Deborah does know of a few more that
she's going to add to this list so we
will be adding a few more but um and we
also we didn't and I mentioned the
strips of Dolan before we met the oplc
once we left as a DNA is examining that
right now so we did not add them to this
list
um but these are the five right now and
uh as you can see we we use the same
layout that um representative evils
commissioned used and it'll have the
year established the associated State
Department the agency comments at the
time and the notes and then we we added
our own staff knowledge so for instance
first one of this listed here
commissioned to oversee the John G
Wynette Memorial we have an expert on it
right in the back row who maybe the
chair of the committee who may be able
to respond to that one
um then we have obviously Commission on
demographic Trends you can see what's
listed there
State procurement County State Finance
commission and the last one the
inter-branch criminal and Juvenile
Justice Council which we staffed but
then again as we say about everything
um after during covid
um it
we don't know if it broke up or exactly
what happened with that so those these
are definitely five that we could add to
the list
and um when it says so we had for the
bullets we have to consider with meeting
with the chairs one-on-one like you
could ask the chairs why if they are in
existence or in staff we can you don't
have to call them in we can submit a
similar questionnaire that represent
people have prepared and we could get
your approval and and send it out for
you and get a response
or whatever you choose or if the member
is here you could always ask them um in
person then
um the next bullet is to discuss uh
their commissions for the potential
repeal if they still need to exist
consolidation or to find out what they
why they are needed because for instance
one
uh member suggested well let's let's
take um subject matter so say education
for instance an education has 20 I'm
just using this as an example it's not
exact but say education has 20
commissions tied to it well 12 of those
may be federally required so that's why
they're in existence
um and you need that to accept federal
funds or if similar with HHS so we do
know that there are a bunch of those
commissions that exist but
um have to exist for reasons other than
just a study
um one thing that Paul mentioned the
other we have this new rule the
five-year sunset
these are all five years old were they
would they automatically just Sunset
because of that well that law was passed
just last year
so I don't so I don't know what the
point the point of five the five years
sunset
yeah perspective I don't we have to we
have to find out with each one how that
uh fits in so after I I have to read
that legislation exactly see how it
would apply or the law to see I would
apply to this I mean okay it's
prospective it's Pro he's naughty it's
prospective I mean I think we even
talked about that we really couldn't go
backwards okay it's prospective okay so
it's moving forward
so everything is created new which
Speaking of created new you have another
list in front of you that lists all the
current
uh proposals for studies this term I
believe the total is 36.
eight of which are commissions
that will be updated because we just
found out about the um
the marijuana commission that just came
across from the Senate so we will need
to add that we will be updating this
list but these are all the new proposals
by subject area so you'll see that's
it's by I believe it's by each committee
which approved those studies
um
and I know that Deborah plans to
um obviously as I mentioned she will
update this and there will be another
piece where Deborah will be here to talk
about the improvements she's been
working very closely with it for data
cleanup and
um
and I.T Solutions because we know that
that's where this all sits in helping us
track all of these and
um as we've mentioned before
the staff has been working very
diligently in the background to make
sure that we look at every aspect and as
each office is working on something and
also we cross over create something that
another office could utilize we're
trying to keep all those lines of
communication and meetings where we can
fit them in while working the middle of
the our current legislative cycle we
also
in the hospital Services we're going to
be working with Dave we came up with
some um another proposal which is a
questionnaire we just did a dummy
questionnaire that could be utilized and
it it incorporates it's it's a Google
Docs it would be electronic it
incorporates many of the questions that
we had in that HCS profile that we
provide for you earlier and we'll work
with Dave to see how that could be
utilized in getting the information
um for future legislation but it's it's
um
items like that that we're trying to
make sure all of our offices are
coordinate because
we don't want to what we did find out is
that many offices in the past we were
all working in our our own silos and we
really need to
um because we have we have a good staff
but we're limited and so we need to make
sure that we're utilizing all of our
resources to um best possible solutions
so
um
anyway I think that's all that we had
Aaron did you think of anything else
that we needed to add today
okay so I think we're all set and um I I
Deborah will probably get in touch with
us if there's other items that she
wanted us to add to today I know that at
the last meeting you had just asked us
to come up with the items that we've
shared with you but as the staff started
working on everything we're coming up
with all these ideas and then we asked
can we have one more week because as I
mentioned sometimes just those four days
between your two meetings
um we're scrambling but we wanted to
present a good product to you again that
can be utilized and hopefully answer
your questions not meet for two weeks so
is that is there more that
it needs to be done for you guys to come
back in two weeks or I I think that um
we'll talk with Deborah as we'll give
you a report on the I.T Solutions and
we'll work with a house key Services
we'll work with um legislative services
and and
um fill in some of those gaps and you
just we will so your list that you have
will be updated of the five will add
more to that
um we'll have a proposed list of
questions that you may want us to send
to the chairs of those commissions
unless you want them to come in and
speak with you
um
I mean we we had people the people come
in
but what we did actually we had the
agency come in that the thing that they
were associated with
and usually the chair or something
and what we usually did was we also
checked with the chairs of the standing
committees if they had any
uh ideas on things which I was just
going to say and I don't know how hard
it would be but
I think it'd be really useful to have
another column on this chart for the
standing committee that's responsible
for the policy yes people do that no the
the standing policy committee that's
associated with these but that that's
the five list of the five yes we will do
that yeah I agree and if we wanted to
check or you know that would also be
useful on an ongoing basis for standing
committees who get this whole big chart
so they can zero in on what their
response is yes we will do that you can
cut it by committee too
yes yeah yeah that's another
well yeah you could reformat the just
the kitchen I wonder if the
standing committee shares know what
their responsibilities are I know what
they're doing
what they're associated with well that
is one of the other charges that you
gave to us last week so that's we're
trying to do with that the entire report
is trying to break it down and that's an
I.T component that we're working on so
education will have that 20 but then
we'll also have a column in there that
says
federally required or whatever that may
be
okay I'm representative Wilhelm has a
question
just a quick one do you already in one
of your spreadsheets already have
uh
indication of which which commissions
are federally mandated
yes they they there are some that's how
we found out when represent people did
her study and that's where we um
that so that should be there but we have
to be but we've had so many
different charts since then that's why
we want to have this final absolute
chart generated from I.T not from House
of Beauty services in the Senate clerk's
office and then the speaker's office we
want one master chart that every office
will refer to so that's what we're
building is taking a while to build that
right so one of those columns would be
Federal and that way we make sure that
we're not
going back and eliminating a federally
mandated so there's a column here that
has the statutory citation so maybe
that's maybe where you could fill it in
so it's funny I see County State Finance
on this this is when I frequently when
I've referred to one that has never met
for eons
but that DHHS made a strong argument for
keeping because sometimes they're just
needed
so I don't know what they'll say now but
that that was the uh that was the one I
was just just as far as listening and
keeping standing committees apprised it
would be good if the chairs or the
Committees had like a running list of
all the study committees there they've
approved
for the house you know like during the
course of a term so they could see
something like this that's why we did
that one of my earlier earliest comments
was that that mapping exercise
to map them all in so they're and also
that would help us identify any
warfarins that are out there that that
aren't recognized by by the Committees
that they have responsibility
and and as you know when you change
administrations or so you have new
chairs there's continuity like
representative hunt knows everything
um yes it all memorize but when you have
some committees have had chairs a
constant change that continuity can get
lost right
well then that's part of the I that's
part of the idea with building this
infrastructure and these new systems
we've got to build uh continuity into
the
program so exactly things aren't lost
from from change to change
I have faith we'll do it
thank you any last com comments or
questions for for Anne
thank you so much
I know this is a lot of work and and
thank you to your team for all the work
it
oh so we're gonna wait for more from
Deborah and then we can sort of make a
plan on what we want to do with the
to any last comments
where our next meeting is going to be
two weeks from today because of Memorial
yeah it sounds like a good time
look at how many people we got here
today
and it gives everybody a chance so get
their stuff together on Monday morning
because sometimes I used to come in and
yeah if you can't full time if you can't
make it please let me know because in
case where it's questionable whether we
get a quorum or not I hate to drag
people to concrete just to send them
back on me I can tell you already I
won't be here
I hope everybody
two liner reminder that I sent out it
and it worked yeah
it's good okay
all right well thank you all very much
appreciate it see you in two weeks and
to the staff again again thank you so
much for your hard work and diligence in
this
in this stuff I know it's a little bit
thrive